На цьому подвір'ї не буває тихо.
Родина Дзусів - це дванадцятеро осіб:
мама Наталія, тато Юрій, десятеро діток і - дві собаки.
Разом вони пережили найстрашніші дні війни Росії проти України.
У цей будинок багатодітна родина заселилася 22 лютого - за два дні до вторгнення РФ.
Коли придбали цей будинок, то ми були дуже щасливі від того, що в нас багато простору, власний будинок.
Тому що ми прожили все життя в квартирі.
Але так склалося, що буквально з перших днів перебування тут у нас були постійні перешкоди.
Село Демидів, у якому проживає родина, у перші дні наступу РФ опинилося в окупації, а невдовзі - у воді.
Наприкінці лютого 2022-го ЗСУ підірвали тутешню дамбу, щоби зупинити наступ росіян.
Село й досі частково залишається підтопленим.
Тут все було затоплено. У нас якраз вода підійшла під двір.
Ми дуже переживали, що залишимося без питної води.
На той момент у родині було дев'ятеро дітей - п'ять біологічних та четверо всиновлених.
Вони боялися. Дуже сильно боялись. Росіяни приходили.
Вони постійно перевіряли. Й не можна було нікуди вийти.
Крім постійної небезпеки з боку російських військових, додалися й побутові проблеми.
Проживання в новому будинку одразу перетворилося на виживання.
У перший день у нас зникло світло, зникла вода.
У нас залишався газ до 8 березня. 8 березня вже зник і газ.
А 7 березня до нас в будинок якраз зайшли росіяни.
І це було стартовою точкою, після якої ми вирішили, що ми будемо йти.
Наступного ж дня пані Наталія разом із дітьми пішки тікали з окупованого Демидова.
Наймолодшій Ксенії на той момент було лише три роки.
Ми пішки пройшли десь п'ять кілометрів. Так. Ми взяли рюкзачки. Всі були там…
Тільки шматочок, якісь там спідні білизни, якісь там шкарпетки і все.
У мене весь час була думка: "Тікать! Тікать!".
Насправді було дуже страшно, тому що ти розумієш, що захистити дітей не можеш, нічого зробити не можеш. У нас підвалу нема.
Пані Наталія разом із дітьми знайшла тимчасовий прихисток у Німеччині.
У Німеччині ми жили в Альтенштайні.
Приймали нас там дуже чудово.
У мене завжди була думка написати навіть подяку,
тому що кожного ранку то нам принесли мед, якась пані нам постійно приносила чудові торти.
Також графиня запрошувала до себе, ми їздили в сусіднє місто.
Взагалі все було чудово. Але все одно хочеться додому.
Тому у червні торік пані Наталія з дітьми повернулася в Демидів.
Будинок, придбаний для щасливого життя, й досі посічений уламками від російських снарядів.
Це в нас та сторона, з якої були всі прильоти, всі уламки.
Але щастя у цей будинок все-таки прийшло.
Батьки маленького Дані зникли за невідомих обставин восени минулого року.
Родина Дзусів погодилася прихистити немовля.
Так місяць тому в подружжя з'явилася десята дитина.
Нам запропонували його взяти в родину. Ми погодилися.
Даня в нас уже місяць знаходиться.
Зараз ми займаємося його обстеженням, реабілітацією.
Були переживання, що він спати не буде. Але взагалі таке враження, що він у нас був завжди.
Та це не єдине поповнення в родині Дзусів.
Узимку сім'я прихистила пса, якого вдалося врятувати із Бахмута.
Жуня й досі здригається від вибухів, але поступово звикає до нормального життя.
Вона під час перших таких тривог, вибухів вночі підскакує, гавкає, бігає по дому.
В перші дні вона гавкала, бігала, не могла знайти собі місця і не давала нікому спати…
Багатодітну  родину підтримують не лише українські, а й іноземні волонтери.
У березні цього року у гості до Дзусів приїжджав британський актор і посол доброї волі UNICEF Орландо Блум.
Це прапор, який у мене висів ще з початку війни.
І коли Орландо Блум заходив, він запропонував підписати прапор на згадку.
Він підписав з любов'ю та респектом до нашої родини.
Візит актора став справжньою несподіванкою для багатодітної родини.
Замість запланованих 30 хвилин Орландо Блум провів у цьому будинку понад дві години.
Час провели супер. Ми порозмовляли про його кар'єру, про взагалі наш стан.
Він запитав, як ми себе почуваємо під час війни. Ну, в принципі, все пройшло більш-менш.
Якщо чесно, думала, що не буде про що поговорити. А якось тема дуже гарно зайшла.
І поговорили, і з малечею пограли, і з нами. Все взагалі дуже супер. І дякую йому за те, що приїхав до нас.
Разом із сім'єю поступово розростається й … будинок.
Пані Наталія з чоловіком взялися добудовувати нові кімнати.
Адже мріють, щоби у кожної дитини було вдосталь особистого простору.
А найголовніше - мирне небо над головою.